oh my gosh that is so fabulous we
welcome to am Northwest Comedian Chris
Turner Chris so great to have you with
us such a pleasure to be with you Helen
thank you for having me describe
freestyle rap for our viewers freestyle
rap is rap that is made up so most rap
you hear entirely written in advance so
you know no danger no stress freestyle
rap is rap that is improvised so like
tight rout walking for the brain and
equally terrifying for the audience I
love it D how did you get into rap in
the first place as a kid you grew up in
Manchester is that right I did I was a
12-year-old boy I'd seen M&M's movie 8
Mile which obviously in England we
retitled 12.9
km and I I fell in love I I wanted to do
what Eminem did so I just started making
up Rhymes making up RS I'd start battle
rapping my friends at school they'd be
like this isn't fair we've had no
practice I was like it doesn't matter
I've destroyed you on to the next one uh
and then I got destroyed in several rap
battles but I persisted and 20 years
later um I'm pretty good at rapping now
now as a kid I mean honestly you look so
young even now so thank you so much uh
maybe not the stereotypical rapper maybe
not so when you started rapping as a
child do your did your parents kind of
look at you a skew oh they They
confiscated all my albums um they did
not like that I liked rapping they were
like can't you do do something how have
you got these photos
where is this
from well as a child I am very I am very
nosy so it's fun to go down people's
Instagram and see their real lives and
pictures that they often forget that
they put on Instagram yeah I'm glad you
didn't put the look at this gecko look
how cute you child look how cute you are
I know can you imagine I cuz I have a
little girl and she looks so cute now
and then I look at myself I'm like oh
God I just it's just downhill
downhill you also because I'm big on on
pets you have an adorable cat Colonel
right I do Colonel wiins which is an old
Scottish word that means
counterclockwise I don't expect anyone
to know um what widin means I would
expect them to know how to pronounce it
though I took Colonel to the vet and the
woman at the desk goes is this colonial
wonders and I like yeah that's what all
British people name our cats Colonial
wonders this is my other cat Indian in
plunder oh my gosh it's so funny okay so
now um we've come up with some phrases
and um I guess we could randomly pick
them you don't know the thing that I
want to know to want tell our audience
is that this is you have no idea about
these phrases now if they're not correct
like if they don't work for you just let
me know and we'll we'll change no no I I
rap about anything anything I yeah
that's the one thing I'm proud of is
that whatever you say I will rap about
with reason I mean this is you know it's
daytime let's you know let's save the
stuff is not a bar gotcha um although I
probably will have a drink later okay
here's one oh this is so Portland drag
queen bingo drag queen bingo love it
let's yeah okay wa we love our drag
queens in Portland should we just start
the rap and we can you can just you can
hold those up and show me when you want
me to switch to rapping about them yeah
oh in the process of yeah why not do
that why not do that let's do it h get
this go ahead start with drag queen
bingo starting with drag queen bingo um
this is entirely improvised made up on
the spot yeah get
ready I like to talk non melodic when I
sing though taking out the ball spinning
round that's the Bingo different type of
balls up in here I rattle in the whole
thing that's a fear I make it so clear
querly you can see me on screen I'm over
there saying hey that's a drag queen
wear in the high beehive looking like
Marge Simpson when you got the stage
that she's on it's kind of like rupall
not unusual there Northwest Pacific yeah
I do all careful there the rain make the
makeup run let me get the next one so
we're moving on come on Helen tell me
what are we rhyming zooming up there
hold it up at the timing okay instruct
I'm hungry in my gut feel a rumble so
I'm going to a food truck I see the
queue move up need to get my taco or
other type of burger hot dog I say so
hold cilantro it hurts on my tongue nope
taste like soap going so long BLS like
me they're eating like two or three
portions I do Wordle every morning if I
get that keep the streak running through
do my first word then I get the answer
into and I'm into that yes my mind it
got bought a year ago by the New York
Times it's not pathetic du the word
games in the pandemic we were going for
it we were like oh yes okay Helen it's
like you know me talking cyber stalk on
the Facebook nosy when you know the most
you're the TV host getting and all the
pictures of my wife and the cat's so
close that's the colonel wein you be
stalking him you're like let me work out
like a gym okay okay no thing that I
fear we got to make sure we keep the
Portland Weird spell it with the E then
the I then the r then the D we're this
adjective in this whole White City
that's the thing that we put to the test
keeping it weird up there in the Pacific
Northwest ah make no mistake my favorite
thing to ask is is this a cake I got to
make sure I get that don't give it a
toss let it rest Lots why I'm a baking
boss I'll be so baked cuz some things
are legal but brownies are tasty and
things being equal I'm always there for
the Savory snacks like a bit of
sourdough that I'm getting it back in my
kitchen switching up I Bel loving I get
my push comes to shove bake the bread in
the oven and then I slice it my wife
says this is terrible it's unleavened
crisp feeling hysterical you need to add
some more of that yeast to say the least
that's the thing needed for that Feast
there we go
that's sing finish that foren and Port I
love it oh my gosh that is so fabulous
Chris you're the best uh give Colonel
and your baby a hug for me okay I shall
thank you so much Helen and have that
drink for me will do